let's talk to alexander gonshar who's
there now
alexander what is it like there
how concerned are you
hello my name is alexander i work as a
manager of compound feed factory in
herson
it's one of the biggest compound feed
factories in the whole southern region
and we were feeding the biggest poultry
farm in europe
around 3 million
chicken layers
and
on sunday we produced the last batch of
feed for the poultry farm
but the truck from the farm could not
reach her sun
so all the
roads are blocked by russians
all the roads are blocked by russian
army
so supplies are cut
the food supply is cut the medicine
supplies cut
were occupied and encircled by russian
russian soldiers
how concerned are you for your own life
and your own safety
with my family i'm staying at home but
i wish to work
i wish to supply
eat to the poultry farm
to do my job but right now it's
impossible because russian
russians occupied
the city
will you stay in your house and how long
can you stay in your house how many
supplies do you have
personally i have supplies
around for
three days
afterwards
i don't know what's going to happen
because
there is no agreement about green
corridor to supply medicine and food
[Music]
if this is
what it is now in kirsten if the
russians stay there
will you be able to live under russian
occupation
no it's impossible
because i claim myself as ukrainian
citizen and i'm going to be as ukrainian
until i die
what will you do will you fight
i believe we are going i'm going to
protest
i'm going to
say that i'm ukrainian and
i want to live my normal life
business life
doing my job
and
be
be as ukrainian citizen that's all i'm
not going to live under russian
occupation forever
[Music]
but is that safe if if the russian
troops come to your door will you say
that to them
yes
how are your family managing
my family
is in very poor situation because my dad
is very sick he has a cancer fourth
stage
and he is dying but he wants to die as
ukrainian it's just heartbreaking to
hear how you are managing
what about your your friends in the
neighborhood the people who live around
you or have they all stayed as well
my friends are almost in the same
situation as me they're locked for
instance my friend is a pastor of local
church
he was about to deliver some food
to the local prison
but unfortunately he could not do it
because russians put a tripwire over
there
so he could not reach the facility
so we are
safe to go out on the streets at all to
do anything like that
i don't feel safety safe to go outside
because russians are stealing people for
instance a friend of mine yesterday he
went outside and we lost a connection
with him
and still we could not reach him
the last thing he said that the strange
boss came to him
and that's all
it sounds absolutely terrifying i can't
comprehend how you are managing to go on
there
i'm really grateful to you for talking
to us today on sky
please stay safe that there
thank you so much